des responsables de génération z
calvados était ça tout à fait aux
étudiants en licence de droit à caen ces
salles universal vu t'as vu ta tout de
suite vu sur les réseaux étaient clic et
voilà côté tout le monde parler de toi
je m'y attendais en fait ouais vas y
avait déjà eu une première vague en fait
suite à ma venue au meeting de nantes a
tout de suite vu en fait vous voyez dans
les truites cité tout de suite les
réactions des gens est aussitôt j'ai vu
que ça
les tweets c'était beaucoup de tes infos
negro ou alors tu fais honte à ta
communauté nique ta race même on va te
décapité si je venais ici et donc j'ai
décidé de porter plainte donc je le
porterai plainte voilà ça commence à
faire beaucoup quand même et j'ai eu
peur même de venir quand même parce
qu'on m'a dit que je venais ici on
décapiterait il s'initie à tpm ça m'a
dit si tu viens à paris où elle là parce
que c'est le mot qui va avec on va de
décapiter donc voilà mais je suis venu
quand même et je vais déposer plainte
c'est incroyable donc tu es venu quand
même oui ça c'est quand même moi merci
d'être là merci d'avoir un panneau mais
c'est moi qui te remercie est-ce que tu
étais parce que tout le monde à paraître
toi parce que tout le monde s'est posé
la question est-ce que tu étais à cette
place et le début d'ailleurs c'est bon
parce qu'on a laissé moi tout le monde
mais je te dis moi je dis les choses tu
vois tanguy tanguy tout le monde dit
ouais à mon avis ils ont voulu le mettre
là voilà il sait ce que j'ai lu sur les
réseaux c'est le genre c'est un alibi
pour eric d ça c'est insupportable
mais tu étais att l'appui les buts
étaient générés depuis le début c'est
moi que voulu mettre là d'accord j'ai
insisté même personne c'est dire à
quelqu'un de l'organisation va le nom du
tout ce mois ci sans doute à mettre
comme ça moi tu met fin aux rumeurs
aulas qui a eu lieu sur le réseau c'est
moi qui ai insisté j'ai toujours voulu
me mettre ici derrière eric zemmour
d'accord non seulement parce que moi je
voulais être le plus preuve le plus près
possible d'eric zemmour pendant le
meeting mais voilà tout souffert du
meeting rt tête il a réussi son
lancement tout à fait incroyable c'était
vraiment enivrant tous ces drapeaux
français cette ferveur j'étais vraiment
content d'être là ça t'a pas gêner
d'apparaître sur toutes les télévisions
n'a pas eu peur non non vraiment non je
m'assume complètement complètement j'ai
aucun problème avec ça ça m'a coûté des
amitiés j'ai perdu des amis vraiment ah
ouais ça raconte-nous était potes quand
ça s'est passé c'est à 18 ans non mais
ça fait quand même déjà étudiant en
licence de droit à 18 ans
18 ans j'étais 3e 2
donc déjà tu m'as mis six classes dans
la tête c'est un truc de foot en 3e
année donc lille s'en servir à nu en
première ligne mais la neige tombée en
troisième c'est pour moi mon travail et
c'est pour moi donc et rsa c'est cadeau
ça tu pars avec non mais c'est fou et
étayent tombe à quettehou ouais ouais
mais ça fait un mois que moi j'ai fait
un bac pro mois d'un combat
professionnel tu as bien fait ce que tu
veux
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce tu
as dit à tes potes tu leur as dit ça y
est ce que je moi j'ai toujours été fier
en fait de leur dire quand on parlait
politique de leur présenter mon
engagement voilà de leur dire que je
soutenir exe moore a très clairement
j'ai jamais eu peur de le dire à
personne pourquoi tu me soutiens eric
zemmour je vous dirais que j'aime parce
que je suis en accord avec ses idées et
avec le constat qu'il dresse concernant
la situation de la france depuis
plusieurs années sur quoi sur le sens la
semelle sur les maigres
le bilan qu'il a dressée jusqu'à hier
parce que hier il a commencé à
développer d'autres choses quand il
industrie etc jusqu'à hier il développé
seulement ces idéologies sur sur
l'immigration ça c'est ça qui me
plaisait tout à fait ça me convient
c'est que sur la sécurité en france
pourquoi ça j'entends beaucoup ça chez
les jeunes oui de ta 18 ans mais la
sécurité revient souvent pourquoi qu'est
ce qui se passe mais parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus laisser
je pense tranquillement en tout cas pour
un citoyen français lambda que ce soit
nos femmes où nos filles se promener
librement sans qu'elles risquent de se
faire agresser ou ce genre de choses je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le risque est
multiplié challans voilà donc tu disais
que ça avait coûté des amitiés tu leur
as dit quoi tu leur as dit je vais je
vais rejoindre eric zemmour à tes potes
et ouais ouais ouais je leur ai dit
alors il naquit monde y mette en huit
rencontres jouées à l'extrême
l'horreur quasiment le nazisme
c'était vraiment enfin ça les a choqués
pour la plupart en fait il n'a certes
rien 16h au kenya afin qu'ils parlent
plus oui mais je m'en fiche finalement
puisque je pense que j ai gagné
finalement et puis j'ai beaucoup d'amis
qui ont dit bah écoute mon engagement et
le tir il est honorable puisque
finalement tu reçois des menaces mais il
tient quand même le coup tu lâches pas
tout tu laisses pas tous tombés et
finalement on papa de nous te lâcher en
plus que voilà donc tu as un engagement
qui est le tien on n'est peut-être pas
en accord sur toutes les idées mais
c'est pas pour autant que l'on puisse
parler